un nuevo episodio en medio de una crisis
carcelaria que es constante en Ecuador
seis presos fueron hallados muertos en
una cárcel de Guayaquil los fallecidos
fueron encontrados con señales de
violencia según el organismo encargado
de la administración de prisiones los
internos fueron ahorcados a las afueras
del centro de reclusión la angustia se
apoderó de los familiares de los
reclusos que buscaban noticias de sus
seres queridos
en el pabellón 5 y mi hermano está en el
pabellón 5 y Queremos saber que nos den
información si en la lista de listado de
estos seis muertos otros aprovechan la
ocasión para intentar ver a los suyos no
se sabe muy bien cómo es la cosa
y yo quiero saber si mi como mi hijo
está en el pabellón cinco que desde que
me lo ingresaron yo no lo veo a mi hijo
las autoridades achacan las muertes a
las bandas del crimen organizado en su
lucha por el control de los centros
penitenciarios específicamente señalan
al grupo Los águilas que domina el
pabellón 5 que alberga a casi 7000
presos de las más de 400 muertes en
centros carcelarios desde febrero de
2021 la mayoría han ocurrido en
Guayaquil el último capítulo de
violencia carcelaria se dan un contexto
complejo para Ecuador en el tema de la
seguridad en las calles horas antes el
país vivió una masacre en un puerto
pesquero unos 30 hombres abrieron fuego
provocando la muerte de al menos nueve
personas